Y
SIX FEET.
THAT'S A CLOSE CALL.
THANK YOU.
>>> IN WASHINGTON, PRESIDENT
BIDEN FINALLY HELD HIS FIRST
PRESS CONFERENCE IN OFFICE
YESTERDAY.
HE DOUBLED HIS GOAL ON VACCINE
SUPPLY, DEFENDED HIS RESPONSE TO
THE BORDER CRISIS, AND ADDRESSED
NEW ELECTION BILLS IN GEORGIA
AND OTHER STATES THAT DEMOCRATS
CALL AN ATTACK ON VOTING RIGHTS.
GEORGIA'S STATE REPRESENTATIVE,
PARK CANNON, WAS ARRESTED LAST
NIGHT AFTER KNOCKING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DOOR DURING THE
SIGNING CEREMONY.
NANCY CORDES IS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT HAVE TO
SAY?
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING,
ANTHONY.
WELL, THE PRESIDENT TOOK
QUESTIONS FOR ABOUT AN HOUR ON
BIPARTISANSHIP, ON VOTING
RIGHTS, AND ON THE RECORD NUMBER
OF CHILDREN CURRENTLY SLEEPING
IN OVERCROWDED BORDER PATROL
FACILITIES.
BUT HE MADE NO APOLOGIES FOR
CHANGING SOME OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S BORDER POLICIES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN INSISTED IT IS
THE COOLER WINTER WEATHER, NOT
HIS POLICIES, CAUSING A SURGE IN
BORDER CROSSINGS.
>> THE TIME THEY CAN TRAVEL WITH
THE LEAST LIKELIHOOD OF DYING ON
THE WAY BECAUSE OF THE HEAT AND
THE DESERT NUMBER ONE.
NUMBER, TWO THEY'RE COMING
BECAUSE OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: SOME MIGRANTS HAVE
TOLD CBS THAT THEY'RE COMING
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE PRESIDENT
BIDEN WILL BE MORE LENIENT.
MORE OFTEN THEY SAY THEIR
MOTIVATION IS THE DANGEROUS
SITUATION IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY.
>> THE IDEA THAT I'M GOING TO
SAY -- WHICH I WOULD NEVER DO --
IF AN UNACCOMPANIED CHILD ENDS
UP AT THE BORDER WE'RE GOING TO
LET THEM STARVE TO DEATH AND
STAY ON THE OTHER SIDE -- NO
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION HAS
EITHER EXCEPT TRUMP.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
>> Reporter: MR. BIDEN GREW FIRE
WHEN HE ASKED ABOUT REPUBLICAN
EFFORTS IN STATES LIKE GEORGIA
TO RESTRICT VOTING.
>> IT'S SICK.
IT'S SICK.
>> Reporter: REPUBLICANS IN AT
LEAST 43 STATES ARE PURSUING
CHANGES THEY CLAIM ARE NECESSARY
TO PROTECT ELECTION SECURITY.
DEMOCRATS SAY THE MEASURES WILL
MAKE VOTING MORE DIFFICULT,
ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR BASE.
MINORITIES AND YOUNG VOTERS.
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT IF YOU
DON'T MANAGE TO PASS VOTING
RIGHTS LEGISLATION THAT YOUR
PARTY IS GOING TO LOSE SEATS AND
POSSIBLY LOSE CONTROL OF THE
LOUSE AND THE SENATE IN 2022?
>> WHAT I'M WORRIED ABOUT IS HOW
UN-AMERICAN THIS WHOLE
INITIATIVE IS.
THIS MAKES JIM CROW LOOK LIKE
JIM EAGLE.
THIS IS GIGANTIC WHAT THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO.
>> Reporter: HOURS AFTER HE SAID
THAT IN A CLOSED DOOR CEREMONY,
GEORGIA GOVERNOR BRIAN KEMP
SIGNED SB 202, A VOTING LAW THAT
CRITICAL IS HAVE CALLED VOTER
SUPPRESSION.
OUTSIDE GOVERNOR KEMP'S OFFICE,
GEORGIA STATE TROOPERS ARRESTED
STATE REPRESENTATIVE PARK CANNON
AFTER SHE KNOCKED ON THE OFFICE
DOOR ASKING FOR ACCESS.
>> ARE YOU SERIOUS?
>> NO, YOU ARE NOT --
>> NO.
SHE'S NOT UNDER ARREST.
FOR WHAT?
UNDER ARREST FOR WHAT?
>> Reporter: PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE TO PROTEST THE VOTER LAW
DEMANDED TO KNOW WHY CANNON WAS
BEING DETAINED.
>> GIVE ME A REASON WHY YOU'RE
ARRESTING HER.
>> Reporter: IF A STATEMENT,
GEORGIA STATE PATROL SAID CANNON
WAS REPEATEDLY ASKED TO STOP
KNOCKING ON THE DOOR AND
DISTURBING WHAT WAS GOING ON
INSIDE.
THEY SAY SHE WAS WARNED SHE
WOULD BE ARRESTED IF SHE DID NOT
STOP.
>> ALL WE WANT IS FOR HER TO SEE
A BILL THAT IS SIGNING OUR
RIGHTS AWAY.
>> Reporter: CANNON WAS CHARGED
WITH OBSTRUCTION OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PREVENTING OR
DISRUPTING GENERAL ASSEMBLY
SESSIONS FOR OTHER MEETINGS OF
MEMBERS.
SENATOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK, ALSO A
PREACHER, HAPPENS TO BE CANNON'S
PASTOR, WAS AT THE JAIL WHEN SHE
WAS RELEASED HOURS LATER.
>> THIS IS DEMOCRACY IN REVERSE.
RATHER THAN THE PEOPLE BEING
ABLE TO CHOOSE THEIR
POLITICIANS, THE POLITICIANS ARE
TRYING TO CHERRY PICK THEIR
VOTERS.
>> Reporter: AS FOR THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN POLITICAL
FUTURE, I ASKED HIM WHETHER HE
PLANS TO RUN FOR RE-ELECTION IN
2024.
HE SAID YES, THAT IS HIS
INTENTION.
AND TONY, ON ANOTHER ISSUE, GUN
CONTROL, INTERESTINGLY HE
DECLINED TO GIVE ANY KIND OF
TIMELINE ON HIS PLANS TO
INTRODUCE PROPOSALS.
HE SAID HE IS GOING ONE PRIORITY
AT A TIME, AND THE